Рік тому Анжела Сущенко із сином чекала
на повернення свогочоловіка Романа з Москви,
куди він поїхав зустрітися із братом.
Жінка не здогадувалася, що зможе побачити Романа
лише у СІЗО Лефортово.
І побачень таких упродовж року буде лише два,
кожний не більше двох годин. Навіть за руки
не можна було потриматися, каже вона.
Роман лише передав їй ось ці малюнки,
зроблені в камері розміром два на два метри.
Вони намальовані синьою ручкою.
Це Женева… Їздили у відпустці.
Анжела за освітою юристка, утім
давно не працює за фахом, займалася сином.
Те, що сталося з Романом,  для неї було шоком.
Інформації було обмаль. Жінка розгубилася
і перші дні не знала, що робити.
Я перші три дні
проплакала,
а потім зібралася,
зібрала себе
і сказала:
«Стоп! В тебе є діти. В тебе є маленький син,
якому тоді було 9 років!»
І треба було якось жити далі і якось боротися.
Хто взагалі знає Романа Сущенка? Хто буде його захищати?
Ці питання непокоїли Анжелу.
Жінка не очікувала, що на звернення її
та колег Романа з Укрінформу  відгукнеться чимало
небайдужих людей в усьому світі,
розпочнеться велика дипломатична робота, коли питання про звільнення
Сущенка стане предметом перемов європейських політиків
на зустрічах з представниками Росії.
Ви ж бачите, всі допомагають!
Усі звернення до кого тільки можна розіслали.
Допоможіть! Якось повпливайте
на одного чоловіка, на одну людину, яка все це вирішує!
Але без батька дуже сумує 10-річний син Максим,
він записав відеозвернення, яке передали прес-секретарю
Володимира Путіна.
Український журналіст Роман Сущенко –
мій тато. Відпустіть його до мене додому,
до мене і мами.
Бореться за звільнення батька і донька Романа - Юлія.
Вона, як і тато, кореспондентка Укрінформу.
Юлія - адміністраторка групи Free Suschenko у соцмережах,
де люди з різних країн висловлюють
свою підтримку українському журналісту,
якого незаконно утримують в Росії.
У тому, що для звинувачень у шпигунстві немає підстав,
родина не сумнівається.
Анжела не бачила матеріалів справи,
судові засідання в Москві проходять в закритому режимі.
Але вона вірить своєму чоловіку, який не вважає
себе винним, і підтримує його як може.
Дві мої, сторінка сина,
сторінка доньки, батьки пишуть.
Плюс Юля робить дайджест новин.
Він в курсі, хто його підтримує,
яким чином …
Анжела показує останній лист від Романа,
де він дякує усім. Жінка сподівається,
що одного дня на щоденне запитання сина про те,
коли ж відпустять тата, зможе відповісти:
«сьогодні».